$50 cheddar cheese this got her like
make me lose ten pounds and clear of my
acne sky
I love cheddar cheddar is great cheese
also if you're lactose intolerant like
me
cheddar is a good cheese because there's
very low lactose in it we're both in a
cheese Club want it or not we're in a
cheese cloth together unless you're
lactose intolerant I don't trust you if
you don't like cheese the cheapest - the
most expensive love them both I like
crap signals I like cheap American
cheese I like fancy soft cheese I like
hot cheese I like cold cheese there's no
way I'm gonna be able to tell business
between cheap cheese and expensive
cheese what do you do it
$50 cheese on first and foremost you can
definitely tell that this cheese aerated
so like Cheetos man that's good cheese
it's super mild it's not a sharp cheddar
oh good hi smokey it's smooth and creamy
it feels like a cracker barrel sir
cheese you know like your store-bought
pick it up in the alley
this is not an extra sharp cheddar I
don't think it tastes like a medium mild
sharpish $50 cheese is not worth $50
yeah I'm not feeling 1500 well I'm up
this cheddar looks much man is it looks
like it had to be like like graded with
a really fine grater Wow
oh this has to do yeah this hat it's
something sharp it's expensive
yeah it is cuz it tastes bad it doesn't
taste bad I'm getting all kind of good
flavors over here ah wow this is rich
it's so full body that has like a whole
array of taste like it's like sour it's
a little bit salty
almost t65 it oh this Jenner is good I
haven't care if it's the most expensive
the cheapest is was great I think it's
the expensive one boy oh boy what a
world of flavor makes your fingers smell
bad that's how you can tell it's been
cheese no my fingers you help your truth
this is the kind of cheese a mouse would
like [ __ ] kill another Mouse for
humor goes tim was more expensive yeah
yeah dude yeah cheese club man okay mine
the second was the expensive cheese a
personal machine agreed
oh yeah man nah but I am upset that the
cheap cheese isn't that delicious
first one cheap second expensive the
second one was definitely expensive
cheese yeah cuz that's what it's done
mm-hmm that cheese was weird it's so
good would pay four dollars for that
oh man that cheese was great yeah Wow
can't get it she's closing not know the
difference yeah you have to know sharpen
is very expensive very nice my fingers
for the rest of day expensive cheese is
not ordinary cheese since the cheese is
what you buy for like your family around
a holiday then you all have some of the
expensive cheese you're like wow that's
really good cheese where'd you get it
oh I got it the cheese market we have a
cheese market like yeah it's on 39th and
Broadway oh my god I'm gonna have to go
like I'll tell my friend Bill he goes
all the time you give you some racks
he's like thank you so much
[Music]